[Applause]
a minute you want to hear a minuto yeah
and actually it was during Co remember
that we had the it was like a SciFi yeah
the screens yeah when I talk to
everybody via screen yeah exactly I like
you physically in person more absolutely
how thank you yeah so wait it's New
Year's now so what what what do youall
do in Venezuela do you have any like
special things y'all do um in Venezuela
many uh there is there is one that I
used to do when I was a kid yeah and it
really really paid off you you go around
I mean when the clock hits 12 you hug
everybody and then you take a suitcase
and go around the block running around
the block and that will give you a lot
of travels you know um during the year
so I did it a lot when I was a kid and
now I'm traveling all the time you're
traveling all the time it works it it P
off do it there's something with grapes
as well right cuz I think they do the
same thing in Mexico cuz I've done I was
in Mexico once and they were like they
all there are grapes at the table and I
think they do the same thing in same
thing so so each each it's 12 grapes for
for the months of the year and it's 12
yeah it's 12 months right yeah of course
12 months yeah exactly so so so it's 12
wishes yeah and then right before the
clock hits 12 then you have to eat them
yes and make a wish for each grape yeah
yeah I thought whenever I was doing I
heard someone and because I was drinking
tequila and I heard them say you have to
eat it in the first minute but I it's
actually have to eat them each minute
like the first 12 minutes so I was like
just just I wanted my wishes to come
true I was just like you I always do I
always do it in the 12 seconds before
yeah I did it I yeah somebody was like
no no no it was like one a minute and I
was like no I didn't hear that anyway I
got my wishes though so there you go um
well speaking of travel enter actually
recently went to Croatia so here's a
video what's happening man oh my God
what is this dance if I only knew what
was happening there I I I feel like I
did this in show choir once I I I ended
up on a boat with a bunch of Croatian
and Bosnian people and then suddenly
they played that music they started to
dance and it just joined in I like it so
yeah it's a it's like yeah it feels good
jumping it's good for a lymphatic
system do you like dancing in general uh
yeah I'm from Venezuela he said yes yes
I love dancing yeah I love dancing makes
me feel so good okay we have something
else in common um you love collecting
watches yeah I do yeah so I love giving
watches as a gift cuz I I don't wear
them generally but I love okay okay I'm
just saying I love watches I I don't
actually like knowing the time which is
weird because it rushes me and I want to
live my life but I love watches like the
art of them are so beautiful I mean what
you love what you love is the is the is
the is the beauty of the watches like
and you write I always get them like um
engraved like with a little message when
you give yeah a that's very cute so you
collect them right I collect yeah I mean
I mean I used to say that I had a watch
collection but actually now it's my
dad's watch collection cuz every time he
come he comes visit then he said oh that
watch's so cute can I have it it's so
cute can I use it for a little bit and
then he just takes it home so
now collections yeah yeah yeah it used
to be mine but now well it's going to be
mine anyway do you get into pocket
watches that's what I'm obsessed with
specifically I just think they're so
cool with but the like you with a chain
oh no I have I well I should I should
look into that oh man they're really
cool yeah but they but you do but but
you do I but you have the chain right
well I give them as gifts like a lot of
time like I've I've done it a few yeah
they're very cool do you have a
significance behind this watch yeah I
mean it was a gift it was a gift for for
a very you know special Premiere at the
you know can film festival in and then I
have this big movie and I walk up this
you know the red this it wasy yeah it
was pretty you know it's a it's a
beautiful life you know I mean it's like
a reminder of that maybe some things
have been done well you know so it's
like I don't know it's a it's a has a
very some things right yeah yeah exactly
so yeah I love that I don't like
anything unless there's meaning behind
it I like a meaning yeah totally because
I'm not really materialistic in general
no no it's it's how it's How the
intention is is is is is bound to the to
the object it's not the object on itself
is is the memories and what you know the
beautiful memories that they bring to
you abely I agree that's why I like
tattoos as well I'm covered I don't have
I yeah I don't have tattoos oh man at
all haven't found like an image to don't
if you find one don't worry then you'll
find 20 more like yeah you get one and
then you're like this is fun and then I
mean mine are all Memories the same kind
of thing mine are all you know places
and things and you can look at all of
them or no not the one I often forget
there's one on my back right shoulder I
forgot and I got that in amster day I
was not high okay I got it because
there's um hanky there he did a lot of
us on tour and we were there touring and
I was like and it
hurt but I did it and it's big big but
anyway um what so I heard that you were
a journalist at one
point what when did that career switch
happen well um you know what and that
and that brings me back to the to the to
the New Year's tradition I always wanted
I always wanted to travel that was I I
wanted to be a journalist so that I
could get become a international
correspondent so that I could travel
yeah and I always and I also wanted to
be a diplomat because my dad was a
military attaches and S of like a
military Diplomat yeah so I wanted to do
something in life that would allow me to
travel and get to know interesting
people and have great conversations and
that's pretty much what I'm doing so I
was like both those jobs entail that
exactly so then but there a there was um
there was something that happens towards
my last year at University a friend of
mine invited me to do a short film and
then I said but I'm not an actor I said
well but I need like someone like you
like an experimental abstract weird um
um short film they called Oh I thought
that he was saying I need someone like
you weird abst I thought he was
describing the character yeah exactly
could have be coma or we coma we like
someone like you coma weird abstract and
um and all I had to do was just to make
up with this girl in a latex latex suit
and a latex suit they bleach my hair I
know that's going to that's going to
bite me that's going to come back to
that's going to come back to me soon I
don't know um well but yes that exists
in somewhere and then and then it turned
out to be a quite you know apparently
decent short film and then it got
selected in a film festival for students
and and then one thing led to another
and then here I am talking to K and
you're so good you're such a great actor
it's so interesting that you haven't had
that dream like since you're a kid cuz
you're so good at it thank you so much
yeah that was a look at hisy serious Dr
Death you can see it on
peacock
man this story is crazy and it's crazy
cuz it's real so why why did you want to
do this this series um because it's
crazy it and it's real yeah and um and
it went on for too long right yeah yeah
yeah it's a it's um it's a
very I love the show and I love I I love
I love the the the the idea of working
with Mandy Moore who's amazing yeah and
to fall in love with her in this very
Twisted love story but a love story
nonetheless so it is true crime but I
think it shows very interesting cuz he
has a love story right at the core of it
and I think that that also increases the
tension because you know that is a
doomed Love Story yeah um um so I I
don't want to give out too much yeah and
the fact that she's an investigative
reporter yeah and then and and then this
guy basically was is a con artist you
know and he and he brilliantly done
brilliantly and he was lying to
everybody but for him it was a fantasy
he was fantasizing he was in the middle
of a fantasy and committed to his to his
to his fantasy
and absolutely that's what it is so so
so so it was very it was a good
challenge it was a very interesting
challenge for me yeah I think it would
be kind of fun if you're an actor to
play a role like that rather than like a
normal like it's it's it's I don't know
it seems more fun to play someone that's
more like out there normally when people
when people when people are the you know
at the unfortunate receiving end of a
manipulation or a deceit the question is
always how could she believe him how
could they believe those lies but that
shouldn't be the question absolutely the
question is how can someone devote their
entire talents to damage other
people not make you sick yeah exactly
but this guy there he will never there
was never an admission of No Remorse No
Remorse no no accountability so yeah it
was Major God complex yeah so I don't
know you've such a great relationship
with your doctors CU I've heard that you
and maybe some of your family members
still have a heart condition so you've
had like a great relationship with
doctors that's yeah that's why that's
why the whole thing was so was such a
sensitive matter for me because I know
how can you imagine if you're a doctor
like that course that's the thing that I
that I I I know how important it is to
trust your doctors you know I've had
very close relationships with doctors
due to my family's you know um my health
conditions and the one that I had when I
was a kid so I know how important it is
to trust them and how much hope you put
in them so for this character for this
person to to betray that trust I mean he
knew he knew his patients names he knew
their dreams he knew their relatives
names and he was able to to take that in
and still betray that is so crazy to me
um well you mentioned Manny Mo um
playing your love interest I love her
easy to fall in love with I mean so easy
to fall in love with her look at that
but how did you guys how did you guys
keep oh my God y'all look like right
there you look like like when you buy a
picture frame at a store you look like
the couple that's amazing that's where
we are we are amazing so how did you
guys keep it light though CU it's a very
intense fil we we hit it off right away
um we met shortly before we start
shooting yeah um in La we shot most of
the show here in New York and and the
chemistry was just right there you know
we we really we were able to trust each
other right away and become each other's
safety net because you know these Waters
were very murky navigate the Waters of
this show um but we're very similar we
have very similar
work ethics and we're both Aries that's
my both leaders okay yeah but we we we
we hit it off right away and we we
really have very similar ways to
approach the the the work so we
committed to the story very strongly and
then by the time we wrapped we were
already back to normal so we we put act
can do that just go in and like be this
other human and then like go to dinner
that night and that's exactly what we
did that is crazy easy you're really
good
liars but you know but but you know what
that's the thing that's the thing and
that relates to my character we're not a
lot of people assume that from actors I
was totally being I know but but it's I
know but it's interesting um because you
have to believe you're actually acting
acting is a is a is is an exp you within
the context of Act of acting everything
within it is fictional but your
relationship to it is real so you're
doing the opposite of line you're
fantasizing yeah which is different from
lying you're believing what is happening
to you yeah
exactly a huge difference so and that
also is what my character did yeah you
know so that's what he did in life he
had yeah so it was like
compation absolutely man do you ever we
were talking in the break how you love
to snowboard you learned skills like
this for movies and Ro do you keep a lot
of those like afterwards well yeah I
mean I keep I I that's cool it was in
Montana oh really that's in Montana yeah
actually where are you at in Big Sky Big
Sky Big Sky so I love snowboarding I
picked it up when I did Point Break I
did the the the the the reboot of Point
Break I played bod's character the one
that the one that Patrick Tracy played
in the first one yes so I picked that up
and then from my boxing movie U hands of
stone um I got the watch from that is
the premiere um I picked up boxing so
for from those characters I I I from
this one I I mean from Dr Death I tried
not you don't take I don't take any
don't take any of those those moments
with you maybe some piece of cloth cuz I
mean he he dressed well oh my God yeah
nice don't you love that sometimes
you're like so can I take this home of
course yeah he's like yeah like my dad
yeah like my dad yeah I like that apple
tree you're not far from it exactly like
I really like these boots can of have
yeah cuz they're nice sometimes like can
I find those anywhere else um okay so
wait a movie that we watch so much in my
household is jungle cruise and we love
you in that but your is crazy you have
all the gross things on you and coming
out of your mouth and all the orices and
I heard your mother was not a fan yeah
she's not a fan she and and and when she
came to the premiere with me yeah um at
Disneyland and then and then it it it
went exactly how I imagined it it's like
the minute like the snakes start come
out of my face then she said like you
didn't tell me you did it on purpose you
did on purpose and she covered her her
eyes and I said yeah they did on purpose
it's gnarly they did a really good job
that was that was neat I looked at my
kids the very first time we watched and
both of them were just like horrified
they were like like it just Frozen but
it's such a great fil snake coming out
of my yeah is it weird to act like that
because obviously we're seeing it once
it's done but you're no it's super easy
cuz they put just like some dots on your
face and then everything is just
computer that does not sound super easy
but okay that's why you're an actor and
I'm not okay well let's do a commercial
break everybody you can see the very
creepy very disturbed Dr Death on
peacock all right we are back here with
Edgar
Ramirez you can see him now in the
peacock series Dr Death it's about a
super creepy doctor who gets way way too
obsessed with his work uh which means
it's time for us to talk about our much
less creepy U hopefully U much less
creepy
Obsession
Obsession oh well I need to say it like
Jesse next time this is my problem um it
was very sexy um I'll hit this button
right here and a topic will be selected
by our super janky super computer uh
then the button does nothing then the
person obsessed with the topic will own
up and sell everybody on it so let's go
I'm first cuz I say
so okay what's up
first oh YouTube okay so my son he's
seven and he loves drawing and he
figured out on YouTube there's like
tutorials that you can literally they
walk you through drawing I can't draw at
all like not good at all M and um anyway
he we follow them we do them almost
every night and we do like the Headless
hem he was like can you draw the
Headless Hors I was like no I cannot do
that and then he found this thing and
and I ended up doing it they really you
should try it you feel incredible when
you're done um but anyway they take you
step by step and we do it all the time I
have a latest one I show I brought it so
you could see this is look at that look
at that that's very cute look and here's
the best part the best part is that my
son is not forgiving at all and he's
like yeah the hat is like way bigger
than it looks that than it should look
and I was like I am so proud of this and
he was like and he was like yeah it's
just he kept bringing up the hat and
then I didn't want to be like look at
yours but like like so I didn't do that
I didn't do that but I wanted to do it I
was like yeah I felt pretty good about
it edar
Prett yeah I would try I would try
tutorials cuz I'm I sh at drawing to I'm
not good at it either but I will tell
you he totally turned me around on it
these people are amazing at how they
teach you like step by step it's like a
line then a line and then all of a
sudden you're like am I amazing anyway
it's not bad amazing anyway okay
no what is this sleeping with FY socks I
can't if I'm not next to a body of water
my feet needs to be covered I'm sorry
wait what if I'm not if I'm not in the
water meaning like on the beach or by a
pool and my feet can touch the water I
need to cover my feet like my feet
cannot be always I always wear socks Oh
I thought you so I cannot I mean I I I I
sleep naked do you ever do this thing
when you get hot in the night though and
you have to kick them off but the the
like in the middle of the night you get
hot and then you kick them off and then
I put it back on no I kick off I kick
off the the blanket but never it socks
yeah it socks stays on yeah see I keep
the blanket kick off the socks and then
I put the back on in the morning cuz I'm
cold we're weird yeah
I yeah uh yeah I mean I was just
thinking that I I I do clip my my
toenails you know so it's not it's not
about like hiding my feet you know I
mean it's not like I'm like they not
gnarly you know like my dad was the was
was in the military so you know like
like like like like like clean nails are
important you know yeah and polish Su
I'm like trying to hide mine right now
I'm like I don't know what mine look
like right now but yeah mine always stay
clean too um I'm hiding them yeah well
look they're just very basic like ever
okay last one this is Edgars go
ahead
Obsession what is this winter hat shaped
like animals I mean you got to have some
fun right so well U it's I just like w
like winter hats with like animal chick
like with funny like funny I guess like
like a act oh there you go yes and you
look like you're having a good time but
you know but you know well you know well
you know what that's that pictures
pictures D like I was having such a bad
time I was so sick when I took that
picture so sick and I was having tea I
was having this Argentinian Uruguayan U
mate tea yeah for the Argentinian is
that really good for you when you're
sick it's really good when you're sick
it's good for everything yeah it's
really good and um and I was wearing
yeah my uh how do you call that frog
that frog frog about caramel caramel
yeah carel we're going to call him we're
going to call him Carmel though yeah
car the accent yeah I love it love it
okay those are our
Obsession be sure to watch show Dr on PE
[Music]
[Applause]
talk thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home